but i want to ask a an interesting
question with the last few minutes we
have before the super chats um space
travel
gentlemen uh i believe everyone here is
religious
assuming aliens exist
should we not should should humans
travel the stars to spread the gospel of
jesus christ to aliens to other planets
to other worlds
you know what's interesting about that
do you want to go ahead yeah well i so
this is actually actually an interesting
question and there's a podcast i love
listening to it's called jimmy akins
mysterious world i'm going to shout it
out he is a catholic apologist he's very
brilliant and he'll talk about questions
like this which is not something you
commonly get so very unique phil's a
great niche he did a whole episode on on
the possibility of aliens and
extraterrestrial life that i would
really suggest the audience check out if
they're interested in that kind of
question but i i personally i don't know
that i would have much to uh to say
about that i'm not sure the theological
implications of extraterrestrial life
what do you guys think what if they
already know yeah right wouldn't it
would it be the craziest thing if like
we land on this planet and we walk out
and the first thing they say is i'd like
to have you heard about our lord and
savior jesus christ i mean the other
thing too is it it tells us in the
gospel that the way to spread your faith
is through kind acts and
by living that faith
yeah i mean c.s lewis talked a lot about
this and wrote you know wrote science
fiction
and so he even speculated about because
we believe in the christian faith that
we're for a fallen
species could you have if if if there's
another planet out there separated by
light years and galaxies could they even
potentially be unfallen maybe they had
their own choice they made the right
choice and then what are the
implications of us kind of mixing do we
do we
almost become sort of like the serpents
in the garden now we're where we are
this the the the tempters
so it's an interesting question i don't
know what the answer to that is it's
kind of interesting to speculate but you
guys ever watch american dad
sadly so uh roger the alien lives of
them but you know stan of course they're
they're christian and so there's a
there's a story arc where um the the the
apocalypse happens and the rapture
happens
and then
when you know all the good people are
raptured jesus is on earth and he sees
roger the alien he goes ugh one of my
father's side projects oh my gosh i love
those funny jokes no it is that is
amazing do you believe in
extraterrestrials i do yeah he loves it
all right yeah absolutely i mean to me
it just seems like a
the classic argument i find really
compelling which is just like a
mathematical certainty basically when
you when you when you consider the
expanse the just the the sheer
unimaginable size of of the universe you
got 100 billion galaxies with 100
billion stars in each one and then each
surrounded by planets it's just the idea
that that that the entire thing is empty
of life to me is a it's just an
absurdity and i don't see any reason to
assume that but i i think that if that
if you someone who says that they think
it's all empty it's like the it's almost
like the burden of proof is on you in a
way that that's that's the more absurd
i take in the opposite direction i hear
what you're saying i think for me i i
would not eliminate it as a possibility
but i would say i would need to see some
evidence or proof that they exist
because the argument is often made there
are so many planets that could
potentially have life on them odds are
there must be life there but the problem
with that is first you're assuming that
life arising is an odds game rather than
an intentional act by a creative god
which is what i believe but even if it
is an odds game you're assuming that you
have some idea of what the odds are so
let's say there's a billion habitable
planets well what if odds are only one
in a billion then it would make sense
that earth is the only planet of life
what if god intended to create life on
other planets yeah yeah exactly
certainly
i don't see it as an odds game but i i
here's the way i look at it it's like if
you if you walk into a a giant mansion
with like hundreds of rooms and you're
just right in the foyer and then you
kind of look around and say i think the
whole place is empty if you were to say
that then it's like then i'm going to
say to you well why are you assuming
that it just it seems like the most
logical thing to assume is that there's
probably people in this house somewhere
but i think i think they're totally
unfurnished and dusty and there's no
shoes around and everything's blurry but
all you but in this case you've walked
in but in this analogy all you see is
literally the foyer it's all you can see
yeah yeah
like what are we seeing or the tiles i'm
just gonna say i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna mock your your perspective
actually because i mean i think somebody
might come and be like extraterrestrials
i know where you're coming from
i just feel like for my my world view i
genuinely believe that that life was
intentional and because of how i believe
the fallen nature of our of our closed
universe really is i believe that the
curse that god judges based off of the
action of man it would be unfair to then
judge that onto somebody else at least
that's intelligent now if there was
something unintelligent or some smaller
form of simpler life form obviously even
the curse of man passes down to animals
and lower life form here so i guess that
could exist however i don't mock that
because i do believe in the supernatural
which is even crazier there's so many
people that don't believe in god think
the supernatural makes you a kooky guy
but then they believe in aliens so i'm
not going to do the opposite back and
like i don't believe
i believe in the supernatural i do
believe there's something else out there
i just do not believe it is physical and
i believe the physical was created here
can i just point out too that i think i
i do think it's strange that there are
atheists who believe in ghosts
yes and energy and stuff but here's the
thing you guys are talking about like
where this fallen that human humanity
has fallen
i think it's really sort of lucky that
we were ejected from the garden and that
we discovered our free will and i think
it gives us a much closer relationship
with god to choose that relationship as
opposed to just being you know the
children in the garden who are naked and
innocent i think it's you know god gave
us that free will
now
we have the free will to love god fully
we had free will from from the beginning
but now we live more separated from god
because of the fall which is is taking
us down a path away from aliens but but
i mean but it also i mean
we would have known jesus christ we
would have no like we would not have
this faith
well jesus it would just be it would be
like a knowledge it would not be a faith
jesus existed eternally so we would
still have jesus christ yeah but there
would be there was no jesus christ in
the garden of eden there wouldn't have
been a need there wouldn't have been a
need for a for a redemptive right saving
act right i think that would be a good
thing i think i don't i yeah i disagree
but ask questions
yeah i i actually i i just want to
clarify a little bit because you brought
up this idea of calling into a house and
you see the foyer and there's a lot of
rooms
my point is not that i'm dismissing the
possibility of saying absolutely no
there's nothing out there it's just that
until i saw someone there had an
indication that there was someone there
i wouldn't assume that anyone else was
in the house well i think just the fact
that the house exists and there's so
many rooms is a pretty good it's not
proof but
you have a pretty good reason to assume
that there's probably people in it
somewhere so i think the assumption that
it's empty is the one that needs more
i'm not even i'm not even necessarily
saying it's empty i'm just saying i in
order to believe in aliens i think i
would have to say yes i think they're
there and i'm not prepared to say that
given what i know so talk so talking
about the the intentionality and god
creates for a reason which of course we
all believe so then what i would ask you
guys is
we have all of these galaxies and solar
systems that we can't even see like we
we can't even look up at the sky and see
that oh it's a pretty light because the
light hasn't been reached us yet
and all just just trillions of planets
everything why does any of that
exist maybe for us for it to be entire
entirely empty but it's maybe it's we
will never see it or go anywhere near it
or know that it's there but it is there
maybe we will one day maybe it's
possible that it needs all of like that
all of that is needed to support earth
that's that's that's true though so i
watched this really excellent lecture by
this uh very christian scientist he drew
an interesting conclusion but what he
said was
jupiter is essentially a filter for the
solar system that its gravitational pull
helps protect the inner planets
and that the earth should be peppered
with much more space debris but jupiter
protects us and so he went on to explain
how we're actually quite fortunate that
life has arisen on earth but it's
because of the entirety of the solar
system that created this machine that we
don't realize in the in the long run
that um perhaps in the development of
life at whatever stage you know one
impact could have wiped out all life
like we already know with the dinosaurs
assuming that is the the correct uh
theory these days they change it very
often but jupiter protects us so the
shape of the solar system matters i
wonder if the rest of the universe
matters too it's all part of one big
machine
i don't know i personally don't think
that uh i agree with you matt that the
expanse of the universe i believe
suggests life probably exists somewhere
else i think so too based on similar
conditions on earth which we've
witnessed and measured on other planets
you know i hope to one one day humanity
will get there and we should totally go
check it out i hope i'm wrong on this
one in some ways because i being
somebody who's who really does love the
physical approach to these things it is
so interesting that with everything
we've put into space and everything that
we've tried to understand that we have
not found the viable forms of life we've
actually tried to look for and maybe
we're just way behind in our development
and our technology and and i and and i
i'm ashamed in that in the fact that i
do believe in like it's good to study
the stars and understand paths and
whatnot but i also
think i don't know going out there just
trying to find life on other planets
they've come here
the life has come here it's like the
navy pilots are seeing ufos all over the
place they're telling us about it
they're like hey guys look at those ufos
and we're all you know what
extraterrestrials what if the the the
reality is
aliens have already come here quite uh
normally and boringly as say tourists
but they get stopped by
intergovernmental panels or like humans
do not know about this you cannot come
to this this is one of my favorite
sci-fi things is when humans don't know
anything about extraterrestrials and
then like some bureaucratic government
somewhere else in the universe is like
just get rid of earth we got to put a
highway there yes i love that well uh of
course hitchhiker's guide works but it
happens in other stuff too where they're
just like get rid of earth i love it i
love that stuff let me let me ask you
guys uh so i we have
we have uh we have launched chicken city
which of course i'm extremely proud of
one of the most super chatted shows in
the world already and uh do these
chickens know what's going on outside
the chicken coop they have no idea what
exists outside there they don't even
know what's going on i don't even know
about the disco party
they're confused by it what if we are
what if earth is a chicken coop
in essence
analogous to a chicken coop where aliens
know that we're here and they just sit
back and watch and they're live
streaming it you know i mean south park
did the the gag that aliens use earth as
a as a reality show sure
generated some super chats you know well
it's for just a cherry in a bowl of
cereal
it's the uh great zoo hypothesis to uh
fermi's paradox that maybe we are just a
great zoo for the universe and the
reason you know all these other great
civilizations talk to each other all the
time and then earth is just
entertainment for them so we're just
not not relevant and that's why they're
not getting back to us on our gold
record that we sent out right there
they're laughing at it they're just like
they sent us these weird naked
i think it's i think that's possible i
think it's i think
it's sort of depressing i always go with
the more depressing theory which is that
um which is that like maybe civilization
just reaches a point where it can't
progress
you you reach a certain point where
self-destruction is inevitable well army
paradox well actually sheamus said we
were we were spitballing some ideas and
james had a great idea where it's like
the year is 2270 and like some guy
travels to the future and everything's
the exact same yeah that's right and
they're like that that was it yeah we
stopped yeah we stopped this is the peak
of technology there's nothing else
just 20 22. that was it huh they dropped
the iphone 12 and we're like well
nothing else to do yes we're done we're
satisfied thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast if
you want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time
you